Кому зимові свята,а кому купа роботи.
44-річний мешканець Риковичів на Волині Петро Іванчук
останні два місяці був на заробітках в Польщі.
Нещодавно повернувся додому і поки ані дня не відпочивав -
каже, господарство терміново потребує його уваги.
Молодець.
Коли Петро їде на заробітки в Польщу - а це фактично щодва місяці,
усьому немалому господарству має давати раду дружина.
Тож кожного свого приїзду Петро намагається надолужити роботу по господарству -
щоб рідні не були змушені просити допомоги у сусідів.
Петро – будівельник, тож постійно їздить на заробітки в інші регіони України або за кордон.
А саме - ще з 94-го року.
Останні 10 років він їздив переважнов Росію тау Польщу.
Але після2014-го - лише у Польщу.
В Польщі, мені здається, надійніше.
А в Росії було, що навіть по дорозі забирала міліція гроші.
Вони бачать, де українець, десь засмагла людина, тобто на будові.
Вони бачать, що на вокзалі, підходять і починають вимагати.
То в Росії так було в мене два рази, що я платив
немалі гроші.
Ніхто з його села також вже давно не хоче їздити в Росію:
серед причин і війна, і безвіз з ЄС, і близкість до Польщі.
В Риковичах мешкають 600-700 людей, роботи традиційно - немає.
І в кожному з майже трьохсот дворів точно є щонайменше один заробітчанин.
Петро розповідає - після запровадження безвізового режиму з Євросоюзом
із села роз’їждаються усі, кому ще немає 45-ти.
Переважно в Польщу, кордон з якою лише в 30-ти кілометрах від села.
В нас є такі, що навітьвчительську роботу покинули і поїхали в Польщу.
Медики теж кидають свою роботу і їдять в Польщу.
Що медик там заробляє- 3000чи-то 3500 грн!
Зазвичай Петро виїжджає на заробітки разом з приятелями - з рідного і сусіднього села.
Про умови праці в Польщі розпитує і його товариш з Києва, Микола.
Він приїхав в гості та допомагає Петру по господарству.
Микола також будівельник і охоче розповідає свою історію.
Робота в Києві є, але покладатись на нерегулярні замовлення не можна,
та й година праці на будмайданчику в середьному коштує лише 70 гривень.
З будівельниками в Україні було 10 років тому добре.
А на сьогоднішній день ціни залишилися для будівельника ті,
що були 5 років назад, а зросли ціни на продукти, на будь-що, на любу курточку…
Треба ж в чомусь одітися, щось треба ще їсти.
Найімовірніше, Микола теж вирушить в Польщу на заробітки,
де отримуватиме приблизно удесятеро більше, ніж в Україні.
Або в Німеччину, де зарплатня іще вища, ніж в Польщі – удвічі чи навіть утричі.
Петро радить товаришу не хапатися за першу-ліпшу роботу,
погоджуватися не менше, ніж на еквівалент ста тридцяти гривень на годину,
та обирати роботодавця лише за порадою друзів.
Він особисто ще не стикався в Польщі з тим, щоб йому взагалі не заплатили.
У найгіршому випадку не доплачували
або роботодавець вираховував із зарплатні вартість проживання.
За житло здирали з нас.
За те, що ми їздимо до роботи машиною.
Тут, дезараз працюю, то все за їхній рахунок.
Житло безкоштовно.
Навіть бувало, що і годували від пуза.
І гроші платять непогані.
Мені сподобалося.
За даними уряду України, після отриманнябезвізу протягом року
за кордон на сезонні роботи виїхало щонайменше 9 мільйонів українців.
Петро розповідає, що без грошей з Польщі його родина не виживе.
Хоча Іванчуки й мають 13 гектарів здебільшого орендованої землі,
на якій вирощують пшеницю та сою, хазяїн нарікає,
що останніми роками заробітку з того ніякого -
ціни на пшеницю, на відміну від вартость палива і добрив, не ростуть.
Хліб є, є чим прокормитися.
А от комбайна купив, він в мене 2 рази поламався, в жнива поламався і восени поламався
Треба немалі гроші.
Кожна поїздка Петра на заробітки - це болісна розлука для його доньки.
І для самого чоловіка також серйозне випробування.
Він показує Іринці, які об’єкти в Польщі будує,
та згадує, як складно було перед Новим роком повертатися додому через кордон.
Годин зо три зо чотири стояли на черзі.
Холодно було, звичайно.
Бо всі на свята додому їдуть.
Там не тільки волиняни
чи зі Львівщини, там і Харків є.
З усієї України туди їдуть.
Петро залишиться удома ще на кілька днів, після чого знову вирушить до Польщі.
Себе він іронічно називає „татом по вайберу“, яким він щодня кілька разів зв’язується з родиною.
Своєї доньці він не розповідає, що на закордоних заробітках втрачає здоров'я,
а лише обіцяє, що не завжди матиме тяжку роботу далеко від домівки.
Як і багато інших заробітчан, Петро сподівається,
що в Україні рано чи пізно буде достатньо і роботи, і гідних умов праці.